covet is exploding again in China the  Chinese government is covering it up and  China just opened up their borders are  we gonna see more lockdowns  Chinese province of Hanan 90 I repeat 90  of the population is infected with coven  while this has not been verified leaked  notes from Chinese officials said that  over 250 million people were infected in  just the first 20 days of December but  what is China telling the public that  there are only around 60 000 infections  hospitals all over the country are over  capacity and understaffed but it gets  worse guess what else is filled Beyond  capacity the morks and what is the  Chinese government telling the world  nothing to see here folks Move Along  people are even being encouraged to  travel abroad without getting a covet  test but now that dozens of Chinese  celebrities have mysteriously died the  government can't maintain this cover-up  anymore subscribe for our full video on  this because now it's all too obvious  that